[Music]
welcome to this week's episode of vmn
where we have a vm skeptic and a vm
enthusiast come together and hash out
all things cloud vms uh brian thanks for
being here
absolutely i think today is networking
right it is networking because last time
you left me off feeling really good
about vms and i'm like this can't stand
we've gotta we've gotta go deeper and
figure it out so
could you tell me from a big picture
overview uh what is networking like once
you're you know using google's
infrastructure and all that
yeah and i honestly i think this is one
of the
the main reasons to consider running a
virtual machine in google cloud um
because the traffic back and forth to
the machine
runs mostly across the network that
google built to serve traffic for things
like gmail and youtube
and the like
so i think that's you know the big
reason
when you say the network google built uh
yeah
that's a that's a very precise set of
terminology it sounds like someone
actually picked up tools and and built
like hardware for this yeah and ran
undersea fiber cable and you know built
a whole bunch of things so we've got
cables we've laid and you know lease
space on other cables um
all to you know reduce the latency
because the the faster
your information gets to people um the
more like i mean
we've just seen research that people
bounce off of pages that are slow yeah
you want to be fast as fast as you can
be
okay so then what's this like for people
that aren't on google like what is the
say say what is the network like taking
google cloud out of it like what's it
like for a piece of traffic what happens
yeah so if um
you know if you've got a machine that's
somewhere you know in a data center or
you know actually even you know on a
home network somewhere um and somebody
else connects to it it'll jump across a
bunch of hops and different like uh
routers and machines on the internet and
make it it's the packet makes its way
there and then makes its way back and
this is
kind of the like we've kind of forgotten
what an amazing piece of technology this
is the internet itself you know it can
route around problems and um get the
traffic there and it may take a
different route depending on how busy
things are and other stuff but
it does mean that there is kind of an
unpredictability in the route and the
timing that that takes so there's a
certain
amount of variation that happens there
right so
one of the things we do
is kind of built out dedicated
networking and you know the traffic will
kind of come out of a google machine
go across google's network and then pop
out somewhere close
to the end user still on the public
internet but fewer hops between them and
the actual service
and i think that's the
the key kind of benefit i guess you know
both for google services and for years
that run here so i think
at a high level the it comes down to
kind of consistency kind of
predictability
of that and then
there's another fun thing that we'll dig
into here of just you know some of these
networking pieces we offer as a service
rather than like a particular piece of
hardware that's doing it i've heard of
software as a service and infrastructure
as a service i've never heard of
networking as a service what does this
mean brian
yeah so the the industry term for it is
you know software-defined networking
and
the the networks that your vms see
are an entirely software-defined thing
and running on top of the networking
fabric you know that you know runs the
data center so we've got this extremely
high speed like well interconnected
physical network and we run a
software-defined network on top of that
and that allows things like firewalls
and load balancers to be provided like
again the slice of a data center instead
of a slice of a particular computer um
the data center is the firewall and the
data center is the load balancer a
firewall is a it's a box that you plug
in between
so what do you mean the fire firewall is
a data center um
yeah so um so instead of a box that you
plug in you know once on the network on
the other side of the network right
um
the
the firewall that you're using uh for
your vms and you know for deciding
what ports are open and that sort of
thing
they're a set of rules and then instead
of those rules going to one box that's
in between
the
implementation of the software defined
network itself enforces those rules and
that's distributed across the whole data
center
and so instead of like having oh my box
can't handle more google can handle all
of this for you
so you get firewall at scale firewalls
at scale
exactly and where that becomes really
important is the load balancer at scale
um
so
um
and it seems like really
counterintuitive so i wanna i wanna
instead of a particular box that you
know traffic hits and it spreads it
around to a whole bunch of back-end
machines right right um
again you're setting kind of rules but
there's still it provides this endpoint
it provides one ip address
um that you see and routes the traffic
to all of them
but there's not just one box doing it
this is insert like i need to know how
this works because this is this is what
google like gmail youtube uses all this
exactly
and in fact we're configuring those same
load balancers and luckily for for us
um
google published a paper about this um
and the the infrastructure is called
maglev so let's put a link to that paper
down below but
at a really high level it allows
multiple computers an arbitrary number
of them so you can just keep adding them
to all implement the same exact load
balancing rules in sync so that you know
when you change the rules
or you know one of your back-end
machines needs to go offline you bring a
different one up all of the load
balancing
you know cluster essentially handles
that for you and there's a like
distributed hashing and a bunch of like
neat stuff that makes that possible um
this listed in that page you're giving
me homework i got to go read about this
now um yep so this last episode we
touched on networking a little bit and
you brought up managed instance groups
if i'm correct yep this this is the
technology that makes that possible
yeah so um managed instance groups i
think are
the kind of like
next level on top of that so once you've
got the ability to kind of route traffic
to a whole bunch of different computers
um how do you figure out which computers
and whether they're working and that
sort of thing that's where managed
instance groups come in into play
okay and so something i keep hearing uh
just repeatedly
everyone says global global google has a
global network
um i i don't necessarily know what that
means uh can can you can you help
clarify
yeah and i guess i made the claim that
you know that your managed instance
group could have machines that are
spread around the globe right you know
so it
at some level it means exactly that
right so our network we've put down
fiber and the we have data centers that
are in lots of different places and
really fast you know as fast as possible
you still have light speed mm-hmm you
know there but there's a physical
interconnect between them
um
and i i think the key concepts to take
away as you're planning your system um
is that we kind of group things in a
hierarchy so the top you've got global
you know something that
you know
an ip address that could be accessed
from anywhere in the world okay
and then regional which might be
something like you know europe or you
know north america or you know asia
something like that
and then
zonal and
conceptually that's kind of like a data
center it's at least a
uh interconnected set of hardware you
know machines networking power
uh redundancy that is all one unit and
and the idea is that if there is a
failure in one zone it shouldn't affect
another zone so you can choose to put
things in different zones and trust that
they're unlikely to you know have the
same you know issue that affects each
other okay so then you get data
redundancy and backups all of that from
zones yeah
so that's how you build reliability you
know into your systems so that you can
kind of keep things separate and the
managed instance group can uh can cross
those and
it's really useful and i think the one
key thing to just kind of keep in the
back your head is that um communication
tends to be
faster within its own and cheaper
things are closer together it takes a
little extra time and cost a little more
money to to cross you know between zones
i think at this point we've talked about
high-level benefits of using clouds
networking i i can't poke any holes in
the argument just now like i it looks
like it's very useful for vm users
um
but i i
i know that can't be like all of the
benefits like you know so what i'm
curious about
what are the other like core concepts uh
we've talked high level are there any
lower level concepts that you're like
this is really cool
yeah so we've already kind of talked
about firewalls load balancers you know
that sort of thing um which kind of
implies kind of public ip addresses but
i think there's a couple other i don't
know just words like terminology that we
should we should talk about a bit um
what you got and you know one of those
is vpc networks and then the other
concept is like how do you connect to
these networks from other places
okay i hear virtual private cloud all
the time uh
yeah i'm confused because i
i kind of thought that's what
like a google cloud network yeah what is
virtual private cloud
i think in this context it's easiest
just to think of it as like the
collection of services that provide
networking for us so a vpc network is
kind of a security boundary if you will
it's the it's the name of our networking
bits um so everything
so kind of everything but
to be more concrete since that's kind of
vague um
when you create a project and you create
a vm
um by default there is a
a network uh that is created
and so we just call that the the default
network um
and it provides
private non-routable ip addresses so the
public internet is all you know on the
main
pool of ip addresses and there's a
couple pools that are never meant to be
routed so routers will never kind of
send them across the public internet so
we use
one of those the 10 dot you know series
of networks as a default and
expose that to
you and all of your vms by default live
on that network wherever they are so if
they're
whatever zone they're in they're all on
the same 10. network
oh wow um
so i can just address them like they're
right next to me
everywhere what about okay here's an
interesting one what if uh so like if i
have a vpc and you have a vpc uh 10.1.1
is that shared like or do we get our own
separate one
yeah so that is a non-routable private
address space so you can't ever have
collisions with other people and my
10.1.1.1 will be different than yours
and we'll you know
the things will never move across uh
that way that simplifies a lot of
networking yes uh okay i'm uh i want to
be skeptical with that
okay okay so let me add one on there yes
the the another thing along those lines
is that um you know when you create a vm
you give it a host name and we
automatically provide dns of name lookup
based on those names for all the
machines so you can just ping another vm
by its host name wherever it is in the
world in whatever network and it just
simplifies a lot of
yeah that that okay animation what about
if i wanted to bring on uh like my own
ip address a public ip address because
this is all private is there a way to do
that yes
yep um there sure is and so we have um
both this com you know uh concept of
ephemeral ip addresses so if you if you
just make a machine and say i want to
have a public ip address and i don't
care what it is you can do that um and
then most of the time you actually want
a kind of long-lived address so that
maybe you can
give it a dns entry and you know make it
mywebsite.com instead of you know a
series of numbers right
and those can be either attached to a
particular vm when you start up and if
you just have one computer that's handy
but often you actually attach it to the
load balancer
and the load balancer becomes that long
lived stable endpoint and the machines
come and go behind the scenes
okay that's smooth
so all right how do i get started with
this uh how do i take like a say i have
something on-prem system
i want to connect to google cloud's
network how do i do this
yeah so
uh i'll take that in two phases so
getting started you know the the
networking kind of is there by default
and then you kind of add the pieces as
you need them you know rules or load
balancers what have you uh but this
connectivity bit um that's that's
interesting right so
the the main one i talked about so far
is you know via the public internet and
we try to get off the internet as quick
as we can but you know things are routed
across there and that's using just the
normal
wide-open protocol so you you may want
to use something that's encrypted these
days that sort of thing if you can but
it's running across the public internet
usually that's not what people want when
you think about hey i want to connect my
servers right to the cloud
and so we have a couple of different
ways of doing that
one is setting up a vpn a virtual
private network and we have
a kind of a hosted ipsec
vpn termination so you can use the ipsec
protocol using whatever hardware
software you have and connect that
to the cloud network and then your
machines on one end and your cloud
machines can just talk to each other as
if they're on the same network
and then you said there's an you said
that was two of the main ones there's
another
and then there's another sometimes so
that's still running across the public
internet but encrypted okay so it's safe
but
you know occasionally you have a use
case where you need to get the latency
down as low as you possibly can yeah and
you know there's nothing that really
beats colocation you put the machines in
the same places right so
we have something called cloud
interconnect that allows you to
um
kind of get
a you know rackspace
in
inside a warehouse listing provider
inside of well inside a hosting provider
that we have a connection with um or
with partners who do the same and so you
get like right there where the the
network's terminated and you know never
leave the private data centers all right
brian i got to be honest uh it's getting
hard to be skeptical at this point like
you're doing a good job
uh
it sounds cool i guess i have i if i had
to ask one last question uh it's gonna
sound like a gotcha but i don't mean it
to be
what are the advantages or why would
someone want to work at this level the
infrastructure level over working at say
the kubernetes level where i could still
work with the cloud load balancer but a
lot of choices have been made i don't
have to deal with all the nitty gritty
yeah and you know there's some real big
advantages to you know having kind of a
curated experience like kubernetes sets
a bunch of stuff up it handles you know
authentication even between you know the
the connections and you know gives you
these
um
nice abstractions you know and so you
get this kind of endpoint you can
connect to so if you're already running
a cluster
i i think you should keep doing that um
that said there's a lot of
you know there's a lot of apps that just
don't run in kubernetes maybe yet or
maybe ever um and sometimes you want to
use a lot of these same patterns and i
think
you know this static endpoint you know
of a load balancer you know in front of
even if it's just one machine
is actually a very useful pattern um and
so
you know i think it's worth
um keeping that in mind
there's a few additional options i don't
think those are
are super key
um but i think i think there's kind of
compatibility with other things that are
going on you know if you've got a bunch
of services you know in kubernetes and
you want to add a few more that are not
in kubernetes um it's really useful to
be able to do that
and then i think yeah you know what we
talked about earlier where sometimes you
have a system that's just
you know doesn't have as many moving
parts and you don't necessarily want to
set up a whole cluster to do that um
it's a really nice way to get
similar patterns
uh with weight loss complexity
that makes a lot of sense and i like
what you said about like kubernetes is a
curated
approach to cloud
um
you don't always want or need that
curation and so it sounds like working
at this level you get a lot of great
power uh and great power you get power
you get flexibility uh and that comes
with responsibility so if you're a
you're a strength trainer or a yogi know
that you have responsibilities
um
actually exactly that and i want to just
riff on that for a moment i think that
um that concept you described there is
true you know across the vms
so you know you you get a little more
control and you have to do a little more
or you can kind of work up the layers if
you know that's the right fit for you
right this is why i like talking with
you brian we riff and it makes me very
happy
um thinking of these riffs in the future
and why i think we should do this again
what uh you said you want to talk about
security in the future so let's
definitely do that what else do we need
to talk about
yeah i think i think the next thing i
want to talk about just because i'm so
excited about them is the the discs go
into more detail about how they work and
what extra capabilities they give you
that you might not be thinking of
you really love disc
i do
you know all right next episode why
don't we talk about disc
let's do it all right well yo uh thank
you all for listening and checking this
out brian
you're slowly but surely convincing me
i'm not happy to admit it but here we
are um thank you again for coming in and
talking
thank you much
[Music]
you